by the way there's one more thing
on the rationality and this goes to elon
musk
if you're interested
49 000 people were killed in automobile
accidents this last year the number was
just released yesterday
49 000.
automobiles are the single largest
pollutant in the country they use up an
enormous amount of energy
they
they use up enormous in our resources
there is a way to make transportation
much more rational
and we've known it for decades it's
called mass transportation it's a really
beautifully maintained crystal clear
clean frequent system of buses trains
street rock
trolleys
vans
it could easily be done in this society
in fact i once did a
project that i estimated cost 30 billion
dollars
that's less than we're sending to
ukraine
to do this to reconfigure it a public
transit system where everywhere in this
country all the major metropolis this
country's overwhelmingly metropolitan
area well it really has to be more than
30 billion but but well it was a few
years ago okay sure
you're saying it but i'm using a lot of
that's insane right it's not crazy stuff
it's a reasonable number right right
listen um but there's a and we'll let me
just finish the point sure yes okay
so
i'm trying to be rational here
if we have a climate crisis which
everyone tells me we do
if it's got a lot to do with fossil
fuels which everybody tells me it has to
do
and and with the use of the fossil fuel
particularly for the automobile
then the solution to the problem would
be mass transit
we don't we're doing nothing to make
that happen nothing
well there's you know on um
you could argue that autonomous vehicles
is a kind of public transit because it's
going to be reusable vehicles it will
end
in theory
car ownership so you just have a more
kind of distributed public transit if it
happens but you know that that's a side
effect his major goal and the major goal
of the other companies that are busy
squeezing to get his share of the pie
smaller so they have some for general
motors toyota all of them are making
electric cars though
so what they've done is they've replaced
the individual car with fossil fuel with
another individual car yeah that's
[ __ ] nuts
what are you doing one that's one of the
things they're doing but automation is
also another one but on the elon side
there's also
hilariously named boring company yes
which is working on tunnels which is
actually expanding the
the the the flexibility you might have
to start playing with ideas of public
transit i think listen i'm now partially
living in austin texas that i don't know
if they know what a public transit
system is period yes um there's most
americans pick up trucks yeah they're
well there's this is an interesting
so
the older by the way footnote the older
the city the more likely it has public
transportation
so you're saying boston is the best
example yes you have you been well yeah
yeah of course yeah i have a place in
boston boston with the street railway
boston is your case study of how to do
this
you